the term cult-classic gets tossed around
a little too much but is it really
always justified on occasion a movie is
so poorly made that it finds its way
into the cult classic conversation by
way of the so bad it's great loophole
more often than not so bad just means
they're actually terrible films kind of
like the ones on this list children of
the corn
adapted from Stephen King's short story
children of the corn takes place in an
isolated Nebraska town and follows a
child led religious cult hell-bent on
ensuring that the town's corn crop
remains robust of course they have to
sacrifice all of the adults to make that
happen
the last bit bodes poorly for an out of
town couple driving through their fields
we must sacrifice them both tonight Amos
was satisfied
we need the woman she'll bring the man
to us no so what went wrong with
children of the corn
King tried to adapt it for the big
screen himself at the author's moody
character-driven screenplay was tossed
aside in favor of George Goldsmith's
ludicrous hyper-violent narrative Lee
flimsy take on the tale even if some of
the film's imagery still colors the pop
culture landscape children of the corn
is a stagnant and ugly film to look at
leading us to question just how this
film managed to inspire its own
straight-to-video franchise Grandma's
Boy there's no accounting for taste when
you're talking about cult classics still
every once in a while a film claims cult
status that just makes you want to hold
people accountable
case in point 2006 is stoner comedy
Grandma's Boy understand that we're
using the word comedy loosely here
because there's really not much to laugh
at in this tale of a 35 year old slacker
forced to move in with his grandma
realistically there are only about four
actual jokes in Grandma's Boy and the
film simply recycles them over and over
and over again what's in here it's just
the kids in a break room or as I call it
the stupid idiot room we get it they
smoke a lot of pot play a lot of video
games and that one guy acts like a robot
what else you got the answer is a
resounding nothing the room in 2003
Tommy Wiseau unleashed the room on the
world and almost in spite of itself it's
become a bona fide cult sensation over
the years James Franco even took on the
feature-length reenact
of what went on behind the scenes with
the disaster artist we can't help but be
a little worried that people are taking
why Zoe's disaster piece seriously why
Zoe's tale of a good man losing it all
looks and feels like a no budget TV show
from the early 90s the dialogue is often
unintelligible and the acting is
embarrassingly over-the-top did not hit
her it's not true it's [ __ ] I did
not hit her I did not oh hi mark
to make matters worse it doesn't look
like any of the cast save for wise Oh
has a clue what's going to happen from
one moment to the next we get it
everyone loves to watch a disaster but
that doesn't mean the disaster deserves
to be celebrated showgirls so you've got
a friend who read a book that says Paul
Verhoeven's 1995 sexploitation satire
showgirls is a misunderstood masterpiece
I don't know what kind of turns that
don't peak a turn that's it with all due
respect to your friend here are three
irrefutable facts that prove just how
bad showgirls is one Kyle McLaughlin is
still shocked by just how bad it turned
out in a 2012 interview he admitted to
being gobsmacked after seeing it to
elizabeth berkley a trained dancer in
real life gave up dancing for years
after the film's release three showgirls
basically ended the career of Berkeley
as well as screenwriter Joe Eszterhas
who was one of Hollywood's hottest
writers at the time although one could
argue Verhoeven was brilliant to exploit
the scripts ridiculous plot and
misguided sense of feminism its
record-setting run at the 1995 Razzie
Awards proves our point dune there's not
a filmmaker on this list with more cult
cred than David Lynch but even the fame
doctor couldn't cult his way into
bringing a successful version of Frank
Herbert's sci-fi novel dune to the big
screen
Lynch's big-budget debut hit theaters in
1984 and was immediately marked as an
epic misfire by critics and his one-star
review of the film Roger Ebert stated
this movie is a real mess one of the
most confusing screenplays of all time
if you sat through all two hours and 20
minutes of the film yourself you know
it's true they'll Lynch shoulders much
of the blame he's not entirely at fault
doom was after all just his third
feature film as director after
small-scale successes with Eraserhead
and the Elephant Man dune was a dramatic
shift in both scale and story for Lynch
maybe a little too big matters only got
worse in post-production when Finance
ears wrestled control of Dune away from
Lynch the result was an absolute mess of
a film the sort of mess that makes us
wonder whether it's cult classic status
isn't merely a reflection on the man who
directed it Mommy Dearest even if you
haven't seen bizarro 1981 melodrama
Mommy Dearest you can almost certainly
quote its most famous line please trust
us when we advise you to leave your
exposure to Mommy Dearest to that
singular moment because the rest of the
film only gets weirder and not in a good
way part soap opera drama and part
psychological horror film Mommy Dearest
takes its story from a memoir penned by
Joan Crawford's adopted daughter
Christina at the center of it all is a
performance from Faye Dunaway that can
only be described as really really big
so big it ends up dwarfing the work of
everyone she shared the screen with it's
the sort of performance that most
directors would beg an actor to tone
down
unfortunately Mommy Dearest director
Frank Perry let Dunaway run with it and
she ran his film right into the realm of
caustic unwatchable camp Howard the Duck
Howard the Duck was destined to claim
cult classic status before cameras even
role mostly because the Marvel comic
that spawned it is the very definition
of cult fiction at the center of the
comic was a wisecracking cigar-chomping
kung fu fighting foul goes by the name
of Howard one laughs at a master of
quack fool
[Music]
yes Howard the Duck is every bit as
bonkers as it sounds it was produced as
a live-action feature even though
director William Hughes believed it
would work better as animation the
film's producer George Lucas was the one
who insisted that the project go ahead
with bold practical effects and a dwarf
in a duck suit we're pretty sure Lucas
regretted that decision once Howard the
Duck is finished the seemingly
ready-made cult classic proved an
absolute eyesore of a film
[Music]